[Music]
I jump right in don't we tell the group
what did you do now for your
professional calling why do you love it
and tell us what motivated you
originally to study what'd you study so
my day job is I am a professor of
psychology so I teach at Columbia
University and I teach in the Department
of Psychology so I teach cultural
psychology everything from how does your
brain change when you go on vacation
- how does stigma and bias and as
outsider identity how does it affect our
neurological functioning our
psychological functioning and our
workplace functioning I also have a
research lab and so just like the movies
it's actually in the basement and and so
we bring people into the laboratory and
what we try to do is we try to study
what I call insider and outsider
dynamics and insiders are people who are
historically say part of a company it
could be the five people that started a
company or the group that is indigenous
to a neighborhood or a country or any
kind of group and then outsiders are
those who are underrepresented in some
way who has some kind of outsider status
in some way so you could think about
this in the context of gender or race or
ethnicity or religion but you can also
think about it in terms of who in a
company went to one particular school
versus another you could think about it
in terms of the founders of a company or
people whose parents have always worked
in corporate America versus those who
are new so what I like and what I have
started to show is that the
insider-outsider dynamics may be vocal
in terms of what the group is but
everybody experiences outsider status in
some context and everyone experiences
insider status in some context and so
I've been doing a lot of work on what
does that look like what does that feel
like what are the neurological
underpinnings and how can we bridge
those gaps
absolutely whenever I talk to companies
a starting point is what is the
structure of the company that either
facilitates performance of all groups or
undermines performance for all so rather
than some looking inside people for
talent looking at personality matrixes
we really need to think about what is
the structure of the company and I'll
give you a couple of different examples
but we're stereotype comes in and
stereotype threat comes in is the
general idea that when you belong to a
group that has some kind of outsider
status and you are in a really hot
performance situation you're taking a
CPA exam you're giving an interview it's
right before year-end evaluations if you
belong to a group of which there are
stereotypes about your intellectual
ability so for instance African
Americans not being particularly smart
women not being particularly smart but
only in the area of like mathematical
performance according to the Google memo
right that way yes yes those in those
contexts there is a worry about being
seen through the lens of that stereotype
and that that can undermine performance
actual workplace performance and so you
can see it on literally when you sort of
take a slice of the brain you can see
that the part of the brain the amygdala
that's associated with with anxiety is
sort of amplify and the prefrontal
cortex a part of the brain that's
associated with learning and memory it's
sort of tamp down but what that
translates into is three things one is
your workplace performance just is not
as good as it could be
- your brain is doing double-duty you're
worried about how others are viewing you
you're sort of you know contending with
these stereotypes as well as doing your
work but three it sort of under lit
undermines motivation so you just can't
give it your all and and I would
actually add a fourth piece to it is
that it undermines your ability to be
authentic so when you think about an
authentic self are you going to be
creative are you gonna bring your
creative self to work you can't do that
when you're constantly
constrained with contending with the
stereotypes and so and and the piece of
it that I try to help people understand
is that it's very very subtle for
instance I was I was working with a
financial firm and a woman told me a
fantastic well for me it's fantastic but
it was but it's not so fantastic a story
about how she was on a panel and on this
panel they had chairs and the chairs
were sort of the height of a standard
man so she's on this bar stool with no
legs in there swinging you know you know
swinging in the it doesn't occur to
people feeling kind of really small and
this is a structural feature it's just a
chair but it's just another reminder
that her identity and physiology is
actually one of outsider status those
chairs were not made for her and you
might think about it well why are we
talking about chairs it's it's one
instance in which it's just a cognitive
reminder of insider-outsider you can
think about this in terms of extra
extramural sports that they have at work
which are great ways to get people to
come together but also it's another
reminder of an insider outsider
dimension those those who can play and
those who can't
yes and even if you can't play you have
to pretend like you can play that's
right
[Music]